如果有看到的话
进行一下这这边的朋友你该是什么呢
也记得碰一下
丁哥站住
你把戴着眼镜的黑框眼镜的大哥
您的闪光灯也没关
我知道大家都不是故意的
我这边也有哦
记得关一下
这边也有
你也是诶这个粉那个桃红色衣服的男士
就你你现在一直在这么硬
对不对
你现在一直在送你
祝你祝你就你快点检查一下自己的手机
左邻右舍好不好啊
我们一起跟旁边的朋友那个互相提醒一下
因为这个这个你你有检查吗
哥不检查你手机吗
你看你转过来看一下
你转过来看一下自己
你就会发现诶会这样
OKOK好好好
大家那个哈
因为实际上是因为有版权的问题
其实我们真的是不能支持鼓励大家拍摄的
但是默默的拍摄就睁一只眼闭一只眼
闪光灯记得关
这边也有一群
你自己检查一下啊
哎对你看你看你就发现了
宝贝好嗯哼话说至此
我已经走到这了
这边有很多的牌子
还有这这位大哥
您的发型让我记得您昨天坐在这吗
对哈哈哈
今大哥您今天也是有这样刮刮头发
也是用洗面奶洗一起洗的
他昨天在这
他就真他嘴跟我讲话
OK天津天津
来自天津的大哥大哥吗
是你你应该叫你大哥吗
你几年三哎
昨天问过嘛
哎不对
你看昨天那个一样八六的
我知道你跟他同年
所以你也八六啊
那我不叫我大哥
你这小弟吗
周年轻小
不好意思哦
略成熟了一点点一点点一点点不
OK还有新疆的朋友
OK王心凌的冰在这哈哈哈哈
OK还有老公
二选一
A胡辣汤
B烩面
胡辣汤吃了啊
这我都吃了
所以这个都可以选啊
好吃我挺喜欢吃
我挺喜欢吃辣的呀
所以不辣
但我可以我挺甜的好吃
你说好不好吃呢
不好吃不好吃啊
我问你啊
中
好了好了好next
想和您终会约会嗯
北漂催婚压力大姐姐求介绍对象
我这就是演唱会很可爱
有时候好像有求知
就是有求职的
然后现在有求婚的
你有什么来您您您多大岁数哈
31岁好
有什么条件吗
重点跟我一样哦
那真不容易啊
这样不行不行啊
哦OK哦
这个可以
他说他的条件就是跟他一样喜欢我就可以了
哇
我跟你讲现场对
发个光明
你好好看一看哦
我们这边现场应该还有很多单身的吗
有好啦好啦
网上这边看的哈
姐姐去哪就去哪
跟着临泉过巡演
OK皮又痒了
所有武汉武汉等我这样
然后穷嘛
P1骂
你是不是我骂你什么骂哇
好都喜欢好
那我就唱歌给你听
我我也是不好意思在公开场合骂哈哈哈
别扫兴
我是在待会可以继续唱歌给你听
好不好
好不唱歌给你听
刚高考完
求比心
OK辛苦啦
还没上榜吧
没有祝福你哦
祝福你哦
那个美好的结果
这不是我靠
是什么反猫
再爱山东一次
OK这边呢天啊
大家都很热情
我这一半都还没点完名
想请心凌吃烧鸡
我吃过啦
真的呀
你应该不是你家的吧
是酒店的哈哈好好好好
你就是昨天摔下去的那个女生
恭喜你哦
是他是他是他
嗨宝贝
诶
你好
合川啊
王思少年多情一定
如今白首望
自古
常言道念不晚叹
如今白首相依
首相思尽太长了
哈哈哈好了
最后一句是不是好啊
哦王鑫鑫凌
我爱你
王王心凌我爱你哦
斜他是擦鞋子琳
我爱你
对斜着的是想的吗
哎呀想的吧哈哈我猜
听见
啊你努力找的
谢谢你哦
可爱啊
像咸湿的王鑫一般都是藏头嘛
他像藏在中间这样斜斜的头大也真好开朗
嗨王心凌
我爱你
我嫁给你
不同意不同意不同意我不同意不同意不同意
我也反对我娶你娶我娶娶都娶
全都娶
我真的太开心了
OK谢谢我没袜子穿了
上周边
OK快很快这样可以
敬请期待好
快到这里来了哦
祝高考好成绩加油
希望你有美好的果实
辛苦啦
在纽约等演唱会好吗
你是你去纽约放假飞回来吗
是啊好
我们会努力啊哈如果纽约的话
纽约见了哈
嗯怎么现在大家都是一些很长的话呢
感谢CEO见证我们友谊
第18年
八零后的你
一定要陪我唱到80加
舍得吗
唱到80岁
OKCI王心凌怎么如约而至
你烤地瓜的弟弟
你刚然后你昨天在那烤地瓜是吧
你八六的
不好意思
因为昨天有没有有没有昨天来的朋友有哦
也是有意识蛮多的
所以大家知道我在讲什么
长沙的朋友
昨天8月168月17没见到你
好
美食林来
我来接你回柳州吃螺蛳
哈哈好好好
没有螺蛳粉
我常吃
可以可以
然后这边还有个东方
我我送你哈哈
快点爱你
视频也是好
王心凌郑耀
你唱
你看他还特别戴着那个帽子
最近大家花招很多很多
每年深生日一颗小星星
今年是第24颗啦
你的小星星今年24周岁啦
哇还有还有还有2030
我第一次有能力支持你
哇
1111的时候哦啊哈还有啊哈哈
就在郑州
就在郑州这里啊
哇哇啊哈哈
好可爱啊
所以你24岁天哪你24岁
所以OK哇也是很长情哦
哈这边还有什么要跟我讲的
哎心灵真的很幸福
今天后来怎么什么
今天我来哦
奔赴奔昨日之约
什么时候下夜的饭饭
周林三用笔记听好听
张培山夜的
我好好好冷静冷静冷静
对温州平阳生好生日快乐哦
带我回台北
跟我合租
哈哈哈哈好好哈哈哈哈哈嗯
我带你好好
我努力把你带回台北
或者是静静
嘿嘿嘿嘿好啦
二楼的朋友还醒着吗
还好的朋友还醒着吗
后面的朋友还醒着吗
哦那我们继续唱好听的歌曲
好不好
好
王心凌
我爱你
王冰冰放给王姐
王心凌说了
我听见了
救到了救到了
谢谢可爱的朋友为你们的努力
嗨你变高了
你能看得清楚